so
[Applause]
jordan obviously this new series dragons
monsters men the first one that we're
doing together this series is focused in
on how men can be men why do you think
there is such a crisis of masculinity in
the first place and why are there so
many people out there who are angry at
you for even talking to men
well i think it's i think you could
think about it as a consequence in some
sense of the lack of a concept of
original sin
oddly enough
i mean people bear an existential burden
you know
it's an intrinsic part of life to
i suppose
to feel guilty in relationship to nature
and to feel guilty in relationship to
culture
you know it's difficult for us to live
in harmony with the natural world
and for the natural world to live in
harmony with us by the way
and
none of us are all we could be on the
social front and
one of the consequences and so we we
have that sense intrinsically you know
that there's a lack in us that needs to
be redressed
and unfortunately that can be
weaponized
and has been and what i see happening
to young men in particular boys as well
not just young men and maybe even
you know
maybe starting at the age of toddlers is
that
we have this sense in the world that
human beings live in antagonism to
nature and that we're actually a
malevolent force
and that our social structures
which are clearly capable of the
commission of atrocity are fundamentally
oppressive patriarchal in their nature
and so then if you're a
male in a society with that ethos
you're
the motive force that drives you into
the world to live is associated with
rapaciousness
and despoilation on the natural front
and then oppression and atrocity on the
social front
it's like well then if you're the least
bit conscientious because this sort of
accusation hurts conscientious young men
the most then the best you can do is
well let's say castrate yourself how
would that be and that would be real
comical except that it's also happening
so i guess that's why that's why i think
there's a crisis and
it there's something serious at the root
of it right because we do have to take
the fact of our
the potential damage we can do
to
the natural world and the social world
we have to take that seriously but the
the
proper consequence of taking that
seriously is not to
commit harry carey let's say in a fit of
moral
anxiety and take yourself completely out
of the game but that's the insistence
now and it's really and i see that
psychoanalytically you know i see that
as a manifestation at a symbolic level
of something like
well symbolically that's associated with
the devouring mother right it's
it's an overweening and destructive
false compassion that has this devouring
quality and
yeah and that's basically where we're at
so
so
you know it's
one of the things that's striking about
the sort of hatred that you've gotten
from so many is that you you've
literally been asked why you're even
bothering to speak to men i mean there
is this crisis masculinity right there
is this idea that every form of macular
and masculinity is toxic and you've
spent your life trying to talk to men
and say no no you can channel that
masculinity in not only a good way but a
necessary and productive and and useful
way and people gotten angry at you for
this where do you think that's coming
from why
it's obviously a good thing that you're
doing why are so many people upset with
you well the thing is i never really set
out to talk to men specifically i but i
did set out at least in part to make a
case for the utility of both the
feminine and the masculine spirit and it
turned out that making the case for the
masculine spirit was something that was
more demanded by the culture let's say
the anger that's a complicated issue we
touched on some of it in relationship to
the despoiling of nature and the idea of
the oppressive and atrocity atrocity
committing patriarchy but then there's
another issue too which i think is
germane
because of family fragmentation
there's a very large number of women
who have just like there's a very large
number of men who
have never had a real word of
encouragement in their whole life
it's a really sad thing to see it's a
really really sad thing to see to see
that deeply and to have seen that
reflected in so many thousands of people
but there are many women who've never
had a positive relationship with anyone
male in their life
and so one of the consequences of that
we know for example that younger women
are more likely to be attracted to men
who show dark triad traits narcissistic
machiavellian and psychopathic and
people who have those traits are
characterized by the mimicry of
competence and so what women want in men
more than anything else is competent
generosity and the data on that are very
clear but you can mimic that if you're
narcissistic and if you're a young woman
you woman you can be deluded by that
it's partly because it points to the
problem of dissociating
competent confidence
from
the expression of power per se
so we could call power
i'll define that as the willingness and
ability to use compulsion
to attain your aims now if you are
someone who
has a proclivity to manifest
power then that looks like
the manifestation of both ambition and
will
and if you haven't had a positive
relationship with anyone masculine in
your life and maybe with not even with
your own internal masculinity say you
can't discriminate between
power and
competent the ambition that serves
competence and so because that's
terrifying because the power if you have
nate had only negative relationships
with men their their capability to use
power becomes such a threat
that
it has to be opposed at all costs even
if it manifests itself within the
say within the
developmental pathway of your own son
and so
so some of that's familial breakdown and
then you have a multi-generational
pattern of that that makes it even worse
and so that's that's definitely part of
it you know there's an ideological drum
that's being beaten constantly
both on the
sociological constructivist front right
that's the oppressive patriarchy and
then on the environmental front and then
you add to that the fact that
well on the leftists especially the
radical types their whole damn doctrine
it's the most pathological doctrine you
could invent if you set out to invent a
pathological doctrine and i i mean that
i'm not making a joke i i really mean
that in the deepest possible sense the
notion that
the fundamental human motivation is the
willingness and ability to use
compulsion power power it's all about
power and every time i hear that now
from someone i think that is not a
sociological observation
that is a confession
on your part and so and it's also just
complete bloody nonsense i mean
all you all know this
you have friends because they're
compelled to be your friends
like
that's definitely not how you have
friends you might have
bully henchmen that way but you don't
have friends
power is an extraordinarily unstable
basis to establish a marriage on plus it
just doesn't work because it turns out
that women who are so annoying are very
difficult to oppress you know so you can
try but
it's not that easy and i don't think
that we've been all that historically
successful in doing so but it's also a
pr it's also a preposterous proposition
because
because
the expression of power with an intimate
relationship does not produce intimacy
or a relationship the best it can
produce produces like a combination of
tyranny and slavery and that does not
characterize the institution of marriage
per se
so there is this insistence among them
among the radicals that power is the
fundamental
motivation and that's and then you think
too
okay you're only motivated by power that
means that we can only get along if our
interests align because if you're
motivated by power and i'm motivated by
power and our interests don't align
and there's nothing else but power
then the only option i have is to turn
you into an enemy and try to destroy you
because
we can't engage in dialogue
that's dialogos and the reason we can't
engage in dialogue is because there's no
logos there's just power so there's no
such this is why it's good thing for
conservatives to understand you have to
understand that the debate about free
speech on campus
in the deepest sense is not a debate
about who should be allowed to speak
freely
that's nothing that's that's a trivial
debate
you can even understand it in some sense
if i don't agree with you maybe i don't
want you to talk but the debate is about
something much deeper which is whether
or not
the idea of free speech itself
is just a mask developed essentially by
europeans to justify the oppressive
patriarchy in the most devious possible
way and the answer the radicals have to
that question is yes that's exactly what
it is and so there's there's no free
speech whatsoever that's an illusion
that's promulgated by people who are
only trying to justify their claim to
power that's what the bloody argument is
about
and so and i just think all of that's
i it's wrong in every way it's wrong
theologically it's wrong psychologically
it's wrong scientifically even
chimpanzees who have a patriarchal
social structure
their social structures if they are
based on the
on power on compulsion
they're unstable
and the alpha chimps who use power are
very likely to meet an extraordinarily
brutal and premature end so franz dewal
the dutch primatologist has detailed out
this wonderfully he's shown that even
among our closest biological relatives
it's the ability to make peace and to
engage in reciprocal interactions that
constitutes the basis for a stable
polity even among chimps and it's
obviously the case that that's
the proper basis for social relations
especially among free people and i've
been trying to puzzle out
especially my lecture tour recently what
the antithesis to
power is or to the will to power let's
say in terms of arbitrary compulsion and
it's something like the spirit of free
and voluntary play
and that's a wonderful thing to know
it's so optimistic we guys were talking
about optimism earlier you know if
you're so imagine this is that if you
structure your relations optimally and i
mean optimally
with yourself with your intimate partner
with your family with your community
the highest level of attainment of that
structuring
is the manifestation of the spirit of
voluntary play and that's so lovely
because there's nothing better than
playing fundamentally and you know human
beings and other mammals as well also
have a biological circuit that mediates
play that was discovered by a man yak
pancep and he showed that
play is unbelievably important to the
development of children
for a variety of complicated reasons
partly because they're practicing to be
competent adults but also that it can be
suppressed by almost any other emotion
or motivation so your kids can't really
play if they're hungry or tired or wet
or or upset
the same would apply within your
relationship if there's stresses and
tensions the play disappears
but if you optimize the relationship and
the circumstance then the spirit of play
can manifest itself and i would also say
that's also the fundamental purpose of
fathers in some sense is to imagine that
paradise that's a walled garden that's
what paradise means so it's walls
structure and then the garden inside is
nature and a nature that's tended
the masculine role in
in child rearing is something like the
erection of the walls
so that play can manifest itself within
the walls that's a real good combination
of security because that's what the
walls are for but then
the kind of freedom that allows for
untrammel development to occur in the
most positive possible sense and so i
would say that
those of us who are standing against the
radicals who insist that the only human
motivation is power
can oppose that in part by putting
forward the observation that the proper
antithesis to that is the spirit of
voluntary play and that's what i hope
we're going to do with the daily wire
you